this is the texas horned lizard a  species which happens to be the official  state reptile and you know what they say  don't mess with texas  [Music]  the texas horned lizard is aptly named  because of its numerous horns the most  prominent horns are the two central ones  located at both the center and rear of  the skull  frequently preyed upon by other animals  its distinct coloration allows it to  camouflage itself amongst vegetation but  when hunted by creatures such as snakes  coyotes and hawks they can either  inflate to a larger size or flatten in  order to blend in with the ground  however their best and more unique  defense against prey is their ability to  shoot a stream of blood from its eyelid  directly into the enemy's eyes  the texas horned lizards population has  dropped dramatically in recent years due  to the state's rapid urbanization  leaving them with a shrinking habitat  this is the texas horned lizard  [Music]  you